[Musique]
voici roumanie canon je ne veux pas que
tu arrives sentant cadeaux aux petits
non parce que je veux pas que que cette
marchandise tiens donne de celui à offre
des fleurs aux dames ça ça leur vin
offre à sabine des fleurs géantes très
gentil qui vient ainsi de l'ariège mais
moi j'ai autre chose à
je ne regrette pas ce dimanche 10 mois
ce qui a là dedans rembarré
qui te rappelle plus ça me parait mou
oui si c'est mou qu'est ce que c'est
qu'il omet du foie gras
excusez moi l'émission est interrompue
jacques ça va plus du tout cette
histoire
dont enfreindrait il ressemble le toit
du boudin
ans et des boudins
et bien les enfants je crois que je vais
me régaler parce qu'il a le nom et la
snia poisson bouyer moi si j'étais toi
je me le donnerait à mois
de conflit je t'aurais la voiture mais
tu peux pas le manger c'est dommage ils
ont
je crois mon boutin
disons romaric quel âge tu as altan il
commande du volet de l'ariège
damian browne est allée à carey est
emprisonné et un prêt voilà
vous voyez c'est pas près 1 enfin les
routes sont ce qu'elles sont mais elles
sont formidables
tu vu avec qui tu as pas maman pas
paraît mathieu
stéphane ravier état est hâtive est est
temps que tu veux tu as tu une échelle à
oui parce que tu as dit gilbert ont la
venue la semaine dernière dans les
journaux
tu l'as bien connu tout a dit gilbert
maintenant elle montre tati gilbert et
le monde sont son mais voilà oui son
papa et maman
lever le doigt on cache les parents
voient la bienvenue dit dont on papa il
est fort un oui il fait quoi comme
métier jeanne d'arc bonjour jean lannes
et toi qu'est ce que tu veux faire un du
second motard motards
j'avais compris moutarde mais j'ai tout
de suite thann et maman travaille à
intermarché intermarché avant le progrès
arrive
est ce que vous voulez les petites
épiceries disparaissent c'est bien
regrettable
alors tu es heureux là bas oui il fait
beau temps oui et les copains sont
gentils oui tu te bats jamais en classe
non avec la musculation que tu as fait
voir tes muscles et j'ai dévié d'autres
la regarde ses muscles et warhammer
à weeds
et qu'ils tuaient des gens c'est le cas
les parties dont les parties dont vous
l'avez pas loupé un alors que des freins
des soeurs non tu es un garçon tout seul
oui et tu voudrais pas avoir des frères
et des soeurs nine d'un frère tu
voudrais avoir deux fois et tu les as
pas non mais qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
des gendarmes
oui le soir au lieu de regarder la
télévision
vous n'avez pas la méthode vous
l'enverrait
vous donner le numéro de la cigogne qui
dessert la région alors quelle chanson
as-tu apprises voilà dix des
maladies des disques avait pas facile
c'est la reine chanté par sabine paturel
regarde sa b2 pas durer comment tu l'as
trouvé
comment
marier avec les contrats d'armement qui
est trop grand tu sais que t'es pas mal
non plus
alors futurs motards nous allons écouter
dans un métier qui sera tout à fait
différent celui de chanteur donne moi la
note
tout petit sur la plaie
jérôme k
déjà
maquet
le emma
il
[Musique]
hu
sur le quai
temps
[Musique]
le
d
coup de mou
pied
non
et d
koulamoutou
après le
[Musique]